puedo suponer que estéis pensando que si
voy a dar una charla de política vaya a
hacer mención a ciertos partidos o
ideologías pero no va a ser así hoy
vengo a intentar transmitidos lo
realmente importante que es la política
en nuestras vidas en la de todos y cada
uno de nosotros y nosotras si os
pregunta si alguna vez has participado
en política me atrevería a decir que la
grandísima mayoría diría que no error
desde que comenzamos nuestra educación
en primaria todos hemos pasado por la
que ha podido ser nuestra primera
experiencia en política y ahora qué digo
esto puede que estéis algo confusos me
explico que nos ha presentado alguna vez
a delegado de clase o en su defecto ha
participado en esas votaciones y diréis
bueno karim pero es que es una cosa de
niños
y seguramente tengáis razón pero la
esencia es la misma os pongo mi ejemplo
yo recuerdo que en mi clase no había
cosa que más ilusión no se hiciera que
esperara el recuento de los votos al
inicio de cada curso para ver qué
persona de la clase era elegida como
representante sería el más malote tu
mejor amiga o es anarquista que se
saltaría las normas y nos dejaría hablar
en clase con el profesor no estuviera
cuando vemos esos niños nos encantaba la
idea de poder otorgar cierto poder a
través del voto a una persona de la
clase
digamos que desde bien pequeños sin
darnos cuenta ya hemos pasado por un
proceso político de alguna manera pero
bueno os podéis preguntar qué criterio o
qué argumentos voy a tener un niño de
seis años a la hora de votar y lo cierto
es que no nos hacía falta gran cosa la
verdad que que uno de los candidatos
fallase un gol a pase a nuestro el
recreo nos parte de una acera o se
colasen la fila para entrar antes eran
motivos más que suficientes para vetar
los de cualquier posibilidad de recibir
nuestro voto
pero hacer política o participar en ella
no es únicamente presentarse como
candidato o candidata o votar va mucho
más allá política podría ser por ejemplo
un grupo de whatsapp de 10 amigos en el
cual deciden a qué restaurante van a ir
a cenar por final de año como es lógico
habrá dos personas por ejemplo que
quieran ir a una hamburguesería mientras
que otras dos se decantan por un vegano
ahora llega el momento del desempate ese
momento en el que estás incluso con el
móvil desbloqueado en la mano esperando
que las otras seis personas restantes
decidan si decante la balanza hacia el
vegano o hacia la hamburguesería ahora
bien imagínate que después de estar
esperando como media hora los mensajes
que empiezan a llegar son los típicos de
él no hacemos lo que digáis es que a mí
me da igual
ahora transformar esas 10 personas en
más de 360 millones imaginar la cantidad
de no es que a mí me da igual que
tendremos en ese caso esto evidentemente
es un símil de la política concretamente
de unas elecciones europeas donde los
más de 360 millones de habitantes de la
unión europea decidimos qué rumbo tomar
decidimos aquel restaurante queremos ir
a cenar es decir a qué partido político
queremos apoyar os voy a dar un dato en
las últimas elecciones europeas que
fueron en 2014 en españa únicamente el
27 por ciento de los jóvenes votó esto
para que lo veamos claramente cogiendo
el ejemplo del whatsapp de antes es como
si de las 10 personas que os comentaba
únicamente tres fuesen las que hubieran
decidido aquí el restaurante se iba a
cenar
en mayo de este año tenemos unas
elecciones europeas de nuevo al igual
que municipales y autonómicas según la
región de españa pero quiero centrarme
en las europeas ya que por primera vez
debido al incremento de partidos
euroescépticos vamos a votar si queremos
seguir construyendo y mejorando el
proyecto europeo o si por el contrario
queremos experimentar más posibles casos
como el de reino unido donde como ya
sabréis durante el referéndum del
preside un muy pequeño porcentaje de los
jóvenes fue a votar mientras que la
inmensa mayoría de la población más
mayor sí que lo hizo esto como
consecuencia tuvo lo que ya todos
sabemos y es que curiosamente las
personas a las que menos años de vida
les quedaban por delante decidieron la
de aquellos que tienen todo un futuro
por vivir a pesar de que tres de cada
cuatro jóvenes querían quedarse en la
unión
por esto es muy importante que
especialmente los jóvenes vayamos a
votar en masa lo que cada joven
considere sea cual sea nuestro criterio
pero ojo con criterio
aún así todavía puedo ver
[Aplausos]
[Música]
aún así todavía puede haber personas que
se cuestionen bueno y porque quiera
votar a unas elecciones la pregunta es
muy lógica y la respuesta es muy
sencilla si no estás sentado en la mesa
del restaurante eres parte del menú y
esto no quiere decir que te vayan a
tener en cuenta todo lo contrario quiere
decir que te van a comer como si no
importas es cuando decidimos no ir a
votar estamos dejando que sean otras
personas las que decidan por nosotros
qué futuro vamos a tener entre los
próximos cuatro o cinco años
os doy un dato porque creéis que tenemos
en europa un paro juvenil tan alto pues
una de las razones es porque los jóvenes
es el sector de la población
quien menos vota en las elecciones
en la europea se defiende una enorme
cantidad de medidas que nos afectan tal
vez muchas nos llegamos a percibir pero
otras son muy directas como por ejemplo
el conocido programa erasmus gracias al
cual millones de jóvenes hemos podido
conocer a otros tantos de otros países
enriquecernos y comprender que son
muchas las cosas que nos unen
el programa erasmus es un privilegio que
hemos tenido los jóvenes al igual que el
poder vivir la explosión de las redes
sociales durante nuestra tapa temprana a
las generaciones pasadas nos vieran
fliparía con esto quiere decir que a día
de hoy tenemos un acceso a una canción
formación increíble para no estar
informados
a día de hoy tendríamos que estar casi
aislados en un búnker bajo el hielo del
polo norte eso sí esto no debemos
equivocarnos esto no quiere decir que la
información que recibamos sea la
correcta desgraciadamente hay mucha
información manipulada bulos técnicos
decir noticias falsas que nos atacan
diariamente pero es que con muy poco
esfuerzo con un clic en muy pocos
segundos podemos verificar en la mayoría
de ocasiones esa información es veraz o
no a no ser que decidamos crear nuestra
propia cámara de eco
como todo esto de la unión europea' las
técnicas y la cámara de eco
suena algo complicado en abril del año
pasado decidí comenzar con un canal de
youtube para intentar explicar estos
conceptos de manera sencilla dinámica y
neutral mi idea era poder humanizar la
política debido a que muchas veces nos
olvidamos que detrás de las figuras que
nos representan hay personas para ello
comenzó una serie de entrevistas
personales eurodiputados y eurodiputadas
de diferentes partidos políticos y
grupos políticos lo bonito de esto es
que todas las figuras políticas acababan
llamando al voto de la gente
independientemente de que fueran
votantes suyos o no no debemos olvidar
que la política es una herramienta que
permite mejorar la calidad de vida de la
gente el problema es que está
herramientas como si fueran martillo
capaz de construir una casa en el árbol
como nunca habías imaginado o capaz de
destruir los pilares del palacio más
grande jamás construido
política es nuestro pensamiento nuestra
forma de actuar es nuestra forma de
respetar los que piensan diferente
también es discrepar pero sobre todo
política es pensamiento crítico
cuando reflexionamos estamos creando
nuestro propio camino y no es tanto en
la forma en la que vayamos reflexionando
sino que realmente lo hagamos es decir
no es tanto las zapatillas que llevamos
puestas sino que comprendamos que
debemos comenzar a caminar y porque ese
camino es nuestro y lo vamos a crear
nosotros es personal e intransferible y
durante ese camino vamos a conocer a
muchas personas que vayan la misma
dirección otras en caminos opuestos
paralelos y otras incluso que vayan por
nuestro camino se desvíen y luego
vuelvan a él más tarde
antes de terminar quiero lanzar una
pregunta a cuantos de aquí los daría
vergüenza decir a quién votaste levanta
la mano o cuántos por ejemplo no hables
de política con vuestros familiares o
amigos
esto suele pasar debido a que al final
la cosa se puede liar o porque tememos
que nos puedan ver de manera diferente
no deberíamos permitir nunca que nuestra
ideología sesgue nuestras relaciones
personales
está en nuestras manos literalmente la
decisión de si queremos vivir en euro en
una europa bajo ruinas o si por el
contrario queremos esforzarnos
informándonos siguiendo a votar por un
futuro mejor para todos este 26 de mayo
tenemos esa oportunidad tenemos esa
oportunidad de votar podemos votar como
forma de queja podemos votar como forma
de esperanza pero vota no dejes que sean
otros los que decidan tu futuro entonces
sean otros los que decidan cuánto puede
cobrar tu madre o cuándo se puede
jubilar tu padre o cómo económico será
el programa de moss en tu universidad
decide tú haz que tu voz se escuche
votando haz que tus intereses queden
reflejados
todos los días tomamos decisiones que
pueden cambiar drásticamente nuestra
vida y sin lugar a duda el 26 de mayo
será uno de esos días muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]